the g8 leaders stood
shoulder-to-shoulder in enniskillen in a
time-honored show of unity at their
annual summit the reality doesn't
necessarily correspond to the display
but the government heads insisted they
made meaningful progress the most
divisive issue was the Syrian conflict
and the leaders struggled to find common
ground in the end they agreed to provide
over a billion euros to deal with the
constantly growing flow of refugees
Germany will pitch in 200 million the
sister gusta it's the biggest time we've
ever paid for a single humanitarian
operation which goes to show how grave
the humanitarian situation is their sons
of Ozzy is the leaders reiterated
previous calls for Syrian peace talks to
take place as soon as possible but they
sidestep the fate of President Bashar
al-assad Russia is a key ally of the
Syrian regime and President Vladimir
Putin warned the other powers against
arming the rebels because you knew Kubra
the bloodshed has to be stopped yeah
that's what we call for and it can only
be achieved through diplomacy talks on
the global economy were less contentious
the g8 leaders said it's in better shape
than last year but still needs growth
impulses there was also agreement on
working to put tax havens out of
business the leaders pledged more
transparency to curtail tax evasion and
avoidance worldwide